you are playing the greatly classic
Crimea villain in Sonic the Hedgehog
it's a mustache oh yeah and it's such
its villain ID that mustache yeah yeah I
grew up loving we talked about how
professor fade in in the great race all
these villains I grew up with nightly
Whipple's snidely whiplash this was and
so I've been really loving seeing that
you brought that back yes we have a clip
here love
dr. Robotnik in Sonic the Hedgehog's we
just throw to it now let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just thought you might like a latte
with steamed Austrian goat milk
do I look like an imbecile of course I
would a lot yeah it's the kind of
positive reinforcement your employees
get yes that's exactly how I treat
people here at the Conan show but that
was interesting because the the piece
were the Tyrannosaurus Rex hologram
bites my head off was a total tribute to
dick Van de you took your head away like
did that and one of the episodes where
he goes to his son's classroom and he
tells them what he does for a living and
he does a headless thing and that's a
total tribute to Dick Van Dyke
he came on kidding this year as well
he's on the second episode he's
incredible he is so he is still you the
guy is so wonderful an incredibly
physical yeah that's right yeah I talked
to him yesterday yeah yeah and he was
thrilled to be part of it and I I just I
couldn't be effusive enough in my praise
and see him in the in not just the Dick
Van Dyke Show but seeing him in Mary
Poppins yeah I was a kid really made me
want to do this I know it was one of
those people who thought hey you know I
like and that that long sort of skinny
look yeah and being able to use your
body that was always able to do it I
mean he's just never stopped he's never
stopped and that's what you hope the
passion for what you do yeah you know
keeps you in that place where you just
want to be a child and you want to you
want to you know stay young and stay fun
yeah never do that again sincerity
slipped out there yeah yeah well just
remember he's the son of a [ __ ] sonic
the hedgehog is in theaters Friday and
kidding airs Sundays at 10:00 p.m. on
Showtime say it eyed area
always such a delight jim carrey thank
you for being here